welcome back to the corporate chess
league
my name is international arbiter michael
j
cummer or as you may know me mike
comer this is going to be an
exhibition match tonight so it's just
winner take all
pride is on the line 2020 was a blast
i don't know if you saw it but john
boyer of
enterprise managed to checkmate his
opponent from edward jones
with .3 seconds on the clock
and they took home the 2020 corporate
chess league
championship they are going to get their
official name enterprise holdings
on the big board on the chessboard
that's going to be displayed in the
chess club
until there is going to be a spring
champion in 2021
maybe it will be enterprise maybe it
will be edward jones maybe
it will be arco construction they are
the brand new team this year
and there are seven teams playing
tonight
we'll have the champions the reigning
champions enterprise
take on arko in the first round
also in the first round we'll have
express scripts
playing worldwide technology otherwise
known as wwt
ascension will be playing bear
and umb they are coming back
and they get the uh by so the way the
scoring works in the corporate chess
league
is if you win your match
will play two matches tonight if you win
your match
you'll get 20 points every time you win
a game you'll get an extra point for
your team
as well and both the the matches they're
back back-to-back rounds
a one player plays wide against the
opponent
and then the following game they play
with the black pieces so it's
back-to-back
matches and um and then we'll have a
round
two around seven o'clock now you may
notice how does umb and wwt already have
10 points
are you guys nuts no because there's
seven
teams one team will receive a
buy in each round so when you receive a
buy you automatically get 10 points
right off the bat
and then if you actually win your match
you can turn that 10 into
20. and okay we've got a game
going on so things are
kicked off right on time right at 6 15.
we are good and this is exhibition
number one 2021 season so
that that's after a great start and so
the first match
we have uh tonight is a battle
of some oldies i love the oldies
klou 1033 way back in the day
we have express scripts facing wwt this
is their
their bored ones old loser is playing uh
the white
pieces for express scripts old path
our oil path is actually playing uh the
white pieces
right up here all path they they tricked
the board on me
okay so o path is white for wwt against
old loser with the black pieces so let's
let's check out what's going on
so we got a french defense though i
don't know how you pronounce it winnower
or venera uh variation
c5 okay uh most people
play uh bishop b4 in this uh
in this line but then if you really want
to be tricky for
uh white if you did play a bishop g4 uh
in in this uh
in this line you can play a very sneaky
move with white you can play queen to g4
attacking the g-pawn all right but the
game proceeds
as such and you know
it probably yep very very very good move
just get yourself out of that pin and
then proceed to castle i would imagine
bishop e2 or d3 or maybe even a check
i always like to throw in some checks
but i don't think
you really want to trade off this light
squared bishop in uh
in this variation the only problem about
going to bishop d3 right now
is then uh old loser could push his uh c
pawn
and just say go away and then i don't
know where you're gonna go i guess
you're gonna go back to e2
so so the the time control for this
event
is game in 10 no delay no increments so
these games are gonna be over in uh 20
minutes
one way or the other and we will
probably get round two started right at
uh seven o'clock
so yeah so he takes and now now bishop
the d3
might be in the works
and then we'll go to uh check out some
other
other games then and maybe we'll see
the hero of uh
of the 2020 champion uh john boyer
let's see what he's up to
let's let's follow him and
see what's going on
i might have to press escape real quick
ben sam because i
can't really i can't really
so usually all the
all these all these uh
they say i'm following but i can't find
his game
so we can watch watch this game for
another a second or two with
with a big check by old loser
and uh see what's going on
where did your game go
maybe maybe he already won his game
john's just that good
jump over to another game here
momentarily
all right here we go uh this is
ascensions board one
ascension is playing uh bear nick
ragone is playing with the white pieces
so let's see how this one
uh started out
so nick is playing against bear's number
one uh
mc nick
hjm
so this is a oh big
check big checkbook let's see if he
blocks it with the pawn
oh and tricky tricky tricky it looks
like he just
oh he took a a pawn that's protected but
now he's going to uh
double attack with his pawn
and so nick throws in another check all
right
and now if he plays queenie two he'll
get the third
check on the board already oh yeah there
it is
there it is how did i know how did i
know
now he's attacking the pin piece so i'm
thinking he's gonna have to play his
queen to
e7 here oh castle
oh this is not oh oh so so
well nick missed the shot because if he
takes the bishop
okay he can be like oh well i'm pinning
your knight to the queen
but unfortunately i can just take your
queen
so it but so knight takes pawn takes
queen takes would be the fourth check of
the day
for for for nick and then he can just
safely castle so there's none of this
rook uh pins the uh queen to the king
shenanigans
and that's exactly what he was thinking
about
and so now he's getting now uh m.c gets
his bishop out of the way
oh now that i like this i like this so
let's see if
he put a is queen and bishop in a
battery
and see if he's attacking the pawn here
yep very good
nobody wants to trade too many pieces
huh there's
that's pretty pretty interesting game um
i give uh
i give white a very very very slight
edge because
i think he is ultimately going to get
control of this e-file
and that could be the difference and
plus
black has these double pawns which look
decent at this time they're not really
hindering them too much but
oh
[Music]
so now yep he had to take i guess
nick knew that because uh he uh he
instantly pre-moved when you pre-move on
chess.com that means
you know if if this move is legal
it's going to be played and it cost you
1 10
of a second so if you see a lot of a lot
of these games will come down to
time scrambles and if you see them
pre-moving a lot
it it still costs you one-tenth of a
second you're like oh
oh one-tenth of a second what's the big
deal trust me it adds up
all right let's check out another game
here
let's check out
uh who else have we uh not seen yet
let's check out money ballin he's part
of the uh
the enterprise crew
see if he's got his game going
um
let's check out uh
oh okay oh oh oh nick
he's got a big fork so this could be
this could be the end of mc pretty soon
because
queen takes h6 is coming
and then queen takes g6 right after
i don't know what nick's thinking about
it's too good to be true nick
that's a that's just a guess but
and this guy loves to check so i don't
know what he's thinking about i don't
know
oh no what happened
oh and oh and worst to worse
he mouse slips as well well maybe it's
not a mouse lip because okay this is not
a mouse lip i thought it was a muscle
it looks like a mouse slip but um if
queen
takes queen
which is forced or else you lose the
knight he's going to get this
as uh this cool knight fork i really
like queen takes h6
check followed by queen g6
checkmate right
ben simon
that's that's scott that had to have
been oh
i am the analyst okay i'm gonna call it
if he plays queen takes h6
check there's only one legal move oh
it's not checkmate he can go to f8 he
can go to f8
but then he's going to get his knight as
well and it's going to be all lined up
do you see that you have
boom boom boom
and then maybe it's maybe it's gonna be
mate
oh wow what a move i did not see that
move
uh that's a very good defensive resource
for mc
rook to
e6 now
it's getting it's getting good it's
getting good
and worse to worse is this knight might
be trapped in a
in enemy uh territory after queen takes
queen
because if queen takes rook takes
and then they play knight up here to
attack the rook but then
rook to e8 and then you're in trouble
can nick find uh something good
this is over here well here we go
so when he plays knight to d8 here
okay well he's got the e file now
that was good maybe he can maybe he can
figure something out quick here
all right let's go back to the uh oh so
opath and old loser their their
uh their first game has concluded
so we do have a a point on the board
for old loser
so that is a good start for express
script
they are currently up one nothing
and let's see how their second game
started we got a sicilian
oh loser of course playing for express
scripts against uh
wwt old path is as new to the league
this year so
and he's right there on board one so
that's how you get good you can just
keep recruiting guys and recruiting guys
from your organization and uh
you know there's a lot of chess players
out there
that aren't united states chess
federation rated
i don't play uscf tournaments and
you know they're they're good so so you
know
put a flyer up at or send an email like
a blast email hey
anybody like chess you know were you
really good at school
way back when you want to get
re-acclimated to it
well we got just the place for you the
corporate chest
double up his pawns
and uh so i i would expect the b5 just
tell the knight to just go away
just go away well let's go back to the
uh nick we're going game that was
getting good
okay so he managed to save his knight
here
there you go
so nick even though it says
zero's all zeros um
okay nick ragone can probably
win a pawn here with knight takes bishop
rook takes check king takes and then
when knight
takes he he could have got that d pawn
yeah i was wondering about that i was
like when is he gonna
finally play c4 and he he finally did
all right let's let's try to get uh
another game here
that we haven't seen yet we might have
some some good ones coming up
so we have oak avenue against vindy
oak avenue plays for ascension
nick or gone's team and vindy plays for
bear on their board too so let's see
what's going on here it looks like bindi
playing with the black pieces is plus
four
and yeah oak avenue really hasn't
developed
many of his pieces yet i would have just
gone all the way and just played rook
takes the pawn right and get that queen
he's got a lot of good moves coming up
oh he just took the knight
and so now he attacks and rick takes e3
was played
so it looks like vindy is gonna win this
one
quite handily but he did get another
piece for it so
so that's good maybe i'll throw in a
check or two
all right let's check out uh well let's
check out the end of a
nick ragon's game nick ragone plays for
the ascension captain he's got the white
pieces in an
end game they're dead even on material
but check out what we got up here
a past pawn
but mc might have ideas of
of playing this move and racing his own
pawn down
to to be promoted
does anybody's guess he's got a big
check coming up
oh he took the pawn
oh this is all right
if you don't respect this pawn he's just
three away from becoming a queen can
nick stop it all right he was smart
enough not to go for the uh
for the the for the b pawn or else that
pawn was unstoppable
c4 was played
yep king in so now he's
he's threatening to take a
check and now is this pawn off to the
races
will nick play it he does he doesn't
care about his bishop he does not care
about it
he wants that queen and that might be
the end of him
can this knight get back somehow some
way to stop this pawn
you can take check and then
he's got no chance can he go
here can he go there
he's out of luck he is out of luck and
the realization
is coming to him because think of how
how much time he's thinking about this
he was so close but that's what those
past pawns do
they're deadly they are deadly so i'm
going to put this one in
in a as a win for uh
for for nick is uh he's gonna get that
queen
yes and smart when you get checked like
this in the end
just to make things easy for you just
stay on
if you get checked by a knight that is
uh
if you're on a light square just go to a
light square because then he has no
follow-up checks and so that was that
was very good
of uh nick and this will be a this will
be an easy win
and we have another result on the board
old path
one again is that true yeah oh
path are we gonna have to
why did why did he resign in this
position
oh he just he just dropped his um
he dropped his his uh bishop
and so he didn't want to play on all
right so express scripts two and
oh so far
and nick did win the game
well you got the he got the he obviously
got the queen and got the win
no stalemates so so ascension is on the
board 1-0
all right we got the uh scandinavian or
center counter defense
uh pretty solid
let's check out vindy's game
vindy playing for bear against ascension
e4 e5 oh
f6 there's an old saying
never play f6 i mean i would be tempted
just to take
well you can't take it maybe you could
play bishop takes first
and then if then if he takes knight
takes pawn takes and then queen up
check and then grabbing the pawn
it's not exactly solid but
it's fun to play and he's just taking it
to him it's
because his king will have to go to e7
and you get
you get two pawns for the knight but his
king can't castle and be stuck in the
center of the board
the rest of the game so it's very
exciting
but it was not to be tonight
and we got another check we got another
check
all right let's just check out uh
let's see how another express scripts
guy is doing
all right we have oh this is this is
they're still in game one this is a very
competitive matchup
don't look at these guys as uh chess.com
rating it's irrelevant these guys are
good
so uh so we have a queen
against a rook and a bishop
but once again this guy's got this guy
and um i like
white's chances
but it is going to be tough oh
especially yeah i was
i was just about to say if i was uh
playing with the black pieces i
definitely would have played
um bishop back here
just be solid you know
and and that's going to be the end of
the wow what how does how does end so
fast
oh he plays check and then he just
takes it and then when he takes back
king takes and then unstoppable pawns
so
so we do have a win for wwt
so right now it is two to one express
scripts against wwt
this is the first exhibition match of
the
2021 season before we begin
the spring league in march and there'll
be
two two matches per
month it's gonna be a six
six uh six round uh
six dates in uh in the spring will uh
will be uh the corporate chess league
spring league
it's not too late to join too next month
we will have another one of these
exhibitions so if you just want to
see what it's all about you know all
that's on the line is a
fun and uh
no entry fee
and bragging rights so much bragging
rights
and then yeah if you say oh man our
team's really good
we'll we'll we'll play in the spring
league try to get our name on the big
championship board just like edward
jones did in 18 and 19 just like
enterprise did last year
enterprise holdings that is and um
and and and you can either hold the uh
hold the board at the uh club and to be
displayed for all to see or you can
bring it into your corporation and and
say look what we did
all right so this is a game
number two oh they're using
john boyer's opening the alekhine
defense
this is actually how i like to play
against the alakine uh
just just make it make it real simple
for you
so maybe slight edge for black actually
check out uh
okay we had the scandinavian this is a
nick ragones game
and uh let's check out what's going on
oh he's attacking the b-pawn
we didn't do anything to stop it so can
nick just go up and take it
i would because you're attacking the
knight if you take it
and he does so now knight attacks
the queen he retreats good
oh an interesting move here might be
knight to c5 trying to box in the queen
oh oh but nick saw
a good move he takes and if
queen takes the knight that leaves this
knight undefended
so now he destroyed mc's castle
he got his queen to safety and now he's
re-routing
to the uh to the king side
oh there's knight c5 just a little a
little too late
he's taken the pawn attacking the queen
queen now
attacks the knight and the pawn
simultaneously
knight retreats but bishop takes pawn
takes and we gotta check on the board
and now well we could have taken the b
pawn
either with the uh
the queen or the knight
probably taken with the knight is better
because then the uh
then you see the queen now can take the
white queen can take the
black knight with check
yep there goes the queens
there goes the the night and once again
we have a oh uh
this i i would have not castled in this
position because you're already in
an end game but i understand
like oh if i play my king up here you
know i could be
checked right there but i would just i
know i said never play f6 but in that
position i would
i would have just played uh castling in
an end game you're losing way too much
tempo you want your king in the center
in the end game
and now you have to worry about things
like back row check mater and everything
so so now white has the crucial d
file here and
and black's rooks are a little bit
passive so i would i would imagine he's
going to double up on these on this file
here
oh now he's no he's got a threat okay so
now
white is threatening rook takes knight
and then if rook takes back
bye-bye other rook so let's see if he
can see
this i'm sure he can um
i just don't know where he would want
his knight to go
maybe back to b4
or you can always just move this rook
off the line
like work here or work here even
yeah i was thinking about that move too
but it's it it's a little bit too
committal though
because your your pawn was nice and safe
on e6 you know
now not so safe it's on a dark square
and he's got a dark square bishop he can
start piling up
and you're probably gonna have to defend
it with f6 now which isn't the worst
thing
in this position but maybe you didn't
want to
all right let's go to uh to another game
here let's let's go back to uh
so this was the alakine game
and uh n burdick is playing for
express scripts well dv dutch
is playing for wwt dvd dutch won
the uh the first one
so they're looking for a little rematch
here
white is playing oh yeah i kind of like
that move
now bishop attacks the bishop he
captures
rook takes and he yeah
d.v dutch wants it
now he wants his bishop so he's
threatening to just play a5 and win the
bishop outright
so it it's a that's kind of a funny
funny thing like if somebody wants to
play a move like a5
you just play it yourself it's just like
nope you ain't playing it i get to play
it so
but it does allow b5 here so the knight
is under attack
and really only has one decent square to
go to is e7 i would imagine
and then you're rerouting maybe oh there
it is on the board
but yeah g5 is coming in quick here too
so
well maybe you can well i would just
play e4 here just
okay my pawn is double attacked by the
queen and the rook and there you go
just push it and then and then he can't
wait to get
g5 in maybe
maybe you harass the uh the knight with
bishop to a3 here
and this knight really has no place to
go oh oh
oh i don't believe this so is bishop
just going to take the rook it does
man you don't really want to give up in
exchange if you don't have to
i mean much better would have been
knight to f1 than knight to e3 if you
really want a piece on e3
and now he's just going for all the
trades here
bishop to a3 or bishop to b2 is
advisable in this position
if you take you're just
you're in a world of hurt let's just say
so let's see what we'll see what ann
burdick thinks about here
these are two very very skilled players
in the corporate chess league
so knight f1 has to be played now i
would imagine
rook h to d8
double up the rooks that way if uh
um so now bishop b2 has to be played
yeah that
that was a game-saving move or else he
would have had
no options
uh but i i think ooh
i might as well take the pawn get the
pawn so
and burdek went from you know down two
points
now just down one point by by the
scoreboard
but you can't really judge the
scoreboard here because rook's coming
down here
and then rick's go don't go there but
then the works going there
to there and soon all his queen side
pawns are going to be gone
rick d1 was played on the board and
you see how all uh and verdicts
pawns are on the white squares that
means this rook is just gonna feast
uh very popular grand master
you guys might know him if you watch our
youtube channel uh
like from the sink field cup us chess
championships
uh grandmaster maurice ashley he's got a
book that's really fun actually
especially if you want to get like
uh you know little kids involved in
chess for you know
for the first time like a a nice
christmas easter book or whatever
um it's called pawn mower
it's just it's just all these pawns are
on the board
and then the rook has to just mow them
down you know one by one by one
and there's like eight to ten and the
puzzles get harder as they go
but he's got it he's got to eat each
pawn if you if you
if you eat a pawn and then can't take
another one you lose so you got to get
the whole it's like a maze it's
it's actually quite uh quite fascinating
and so i would imagine dv dutch uh
knows that and he's just gonna mow down
these pawns all right let's take
let's take a look back at uh nick
ragon's game
we got uh double rooks
wow what is going on nick is playing
the black pieces here so check so he's
got a draw here if he wants it he can
just
check rook rook this is when you want to
be following
in this team event this is this is what
you want to know because in order to get
that 20-point match
victory right you just need to score
more points than uh your opponents right
so in order for ascension to to defeat
bear in this match
they need uh there's
there's six total matches so all they
need is three and a half points
obviously you see nick already won a
game so you know if
if if i have three points if i see my
team has three points i'm just going to
go for that perpetual check
even though i'm theoretically winning
computers got me plus two on the
scoreboard but this is when you it pays
to know the
the the match situation
but i know you wanna yeah you always
wanna win
but in in team events
you win when your team wins not
necessarily when you win
or draw sometimes you can lose and still
win so it's a
there's a lot of ways to win
all right so and we got another deadly
pawn here
just two away from becoming a queen and
and the tide will turn quick
and you don't really want to let this
guy
loose by playing this check either
maybe you could maybe you could play f5
here
oh you let him loose in this position if
you if he would have played
instead of the check if you would have
played f5 you might be threatening
rook g4 check and then he's only got
king h5 and then he just swoops the
other rook in for mate
so so now the king is loose
and this guy is too away from getting a
queen i know
i know he's got ways to stop it but it's
dangerous i would have just well i would
have looked at the
match situation and saw what was going
on but now he's got his pawn going
i i love it when and in team situations
you should never
ever resign in the first place but you
know if you play the game out to victory
or you know all the way out you know 50
60 moves usually it's going to end with
a pawn promotion
and here we go whose pawn is going to be
faster
it's a race what
you play rook up here i wouldn't play
rook up here because then if he takes
oh he can just take the pawn
good move
nick knew what he was doing all along
we'll have to check with uh
ryan chester later tonight to see if
there's a
a brilliancy move i i don't know why
that that tactic always um
always gets me it's like i know it
i've done puzzles with it but sometimes
i just
still overlook that he can just take
that pawn because
removing the defender so now
if i'm white i have to play this move
but now i'm in a world of hurt because
i'm down three pawns to
zero
well i mean i know it's theoretically
four pawns right now but
well actually he can't really take it so
it will be four pawns to zero
and now you just play f5 if just move
them on
up or the h pawn anybody but the g i
wouldn't
i wouldn't push the g pawn
oh you could take it take it slow too
and that is going to be in the books
nick wins two points yeah who wants the
draw
anyway when you can get and every point
does count
in the uh corporate chess league because
you get the 20 points
for the team victory but each individual
uh point also so if like
the rest of ascension would have lost
i'm not saying that they did
but uh ascension would still have two
points on the board
you know so every point individual score
does
add to your team total as well hopefully
that makes sense to everyone
oh and oh it is are they trying to start
round
oh they're just playing for fun this
this is
not part of the uh the tournament here
but this
this one is and then probably once this
game uh
concludes ben simon maybe we'll take a
quick break and then we can update the
scores
i'm sorry there's lots of problems
what's happening oh oh no i was saying
once this game concludes uh can we take
a
short break and then we'll update
everybody on the scoreboard
okay so so i know they show the
standings
underneath there um
let's just say those are provisional
okay
and we'll update with the uh with the 20
point victories and all that
uh when we come back from break in just
a minute but we'll see this uh
this exciting conclusion to this game
and as you see
it's all down to the past pawns again
here we go
and it looks like uh dv dutch is going
to win
for his team here because he can just
play rook takes knight check
king takes and then queen and then this
will be
pretty easy for um for dv dutch
yep just yeah just try to eliminate all
hope as fast as possible
which is great idea
and now he can just play queen here and
uh well
actually you probably don't even want to
play queen there yeah you just oh now
now you want to play
queen there when when you get when you
get a pawn part
oh and he's just toying with him
oh but it didn't work
oh no dv dutch
got too excited had no reason to play
queen takes
check but he sacrifices pawn
and um and verdict escapes with the draw
and maybe that will maybe that will uh
impact the standings uh
big time we'll have to we'll have to
come back and see
uh we'll be going to a commercial break
hopefully not for uh
too long we're just gonna uh you know
compute some stuff and we'll give you
the uh up-to-date standings
uh here in a couple minutes okay
stand by for uh round two right after
this
well i'm alex kurford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to
the pandemic and covet 19 we were able
to gather here
in the chess club meet face to face and
have games on a quarterly basis it was a
lot of fun
had a high level of engagement and
people beginning
to be attracted to that edward jones has
been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on the corporate chess league
once a month here at edward jones we
actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page
and be able to see and interact with
each other
in a virtual way and then partnering
with chess.com we're able to provide
the the actual tournament and and how
the competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of uh you know
rib each other a little bit and and it
is a little friendly banter which we
love
and all during that time the st louis
chess club is hosting
a youtube channel that has commentary
from
guest speakers grand masters
international masters
commentating on how the games are
actually going
that makes for a lot of fun for people
to be able to
see how their friends how their
colleagues are doing
during a game by having a professional
be able to speak about
the position and and have fun that way
too
i think during this time it is hard
to have motivation sometimes we can get
down on things having an
outlet where competition can still be
involved in your life having an outlet
where you can still have
networking with your colleagues has
really been a key part of the success of
the corporate chess league
it has been really fun to be able to not
only get to know the people in my own
firm better and share that that similar
passion
but also get to know people from several
different
firms here in in the st louis area
we've continued to have interest in the
corporate chess league
both here in the st louis area and
beyond
we're looking forward to a great season
in 2021
if you or your company is interested
in being a part of the corporate chess
league you can go to
www.stlouischessclub.org
and get more information we'd love to
have you be a part of the competition
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end
has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments
including the u.s chess championships
and the sinkfield cup
one of the strongest chess tournaments
globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess
to children throughout the st louis area
research shows
children who play chess exhibit improved
analytical skills and increased
confidence
the chess club is highly engaged with
the local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club
is the world chess hall of fame this
one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess
in imaginative ways and is home to the
us and world chess
halls of faint cutting-edge exhibitions
feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art
innovative programming explores the
intersection of chess
art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions
and monthly music in the galleries the
world chess hall of fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched
to learn more about the st louis chess
campus visit stlchestcampus.org
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to
the pandemic and covet 19 we were able
to gather here
in the chess club meet face
welcome back to round two
of the corporate chess league exhibition
number one of 2021
and we have the updated standings
all right so enterprise has
29 points after round one
next we have umb with 23.
ascension has 16.
nick rigon was the hero of that
of that match he may have known the
match situation
because they were able to draw
their round one match against bear
and he needed to win his his uh
his final game and that uh rook ending
so if he would have just taken that
uh repetition draw
ascension would be sitting with just
well
five and a half points so they got uh 10
points for the draw
with bear the reason why bear has 13 and
ascension actually has 16 even though
they drew that first match
his ascension brought more players and
they played some
extra games against uh the team with
dubai
and they they were very successful and
then express scripts
one and a half and orco who had to play
enterprise
they they got they got fed to the
champions uh first time around so it had
a tough matchup
and it's uh and now the one team i did
not uh
tell you about is worldwide technology
wwt
they scored 26 and a half points in the
first uh
first round and then got a 10 point
buy in round two as we have uneven teams
so wwt
in this round has a chance to to get an
additional 10 points uh if they uh
if they beat the extra players in uh
in round two so the matchups for round
two
and we are underway here so we'll get to
uh to a game shortly
but we'll have enterprise against umb
and there's just two players for uh umb
when we get into the regular
season that's the spring league you will
have to bring a minimum
of four players at least but you could
bring you know
10 to 12 players because the more points
like ascension brought more players than
bear
and now they have more points than bear
so but
for the for this exhibition you can just
bring one or two or three
players and so enterprise their their
big two
tim nisham and and the hero from 2020
john boyer
will be playing umb express scripts
will be playing ascension arco
against bear and then wwt
will be playing a bunch of extra players
to try it
and get an additional 10 points plus
every
uh every individual when they get
they'll get a point too
so they could they could amass a lot of
points tonight so
let's get right into these games we'll
have uh
let's go with uh who haven't we
let's go with uh board two
for enterprise against uh
umb here and uh
we'll have a big daddy jazz 64
playing for enterprise the reigning
champions
against umb
and and let's see i mean this is a
battle for first place possibly
hey gotta get my hair got to get my hair
yeah yeah he knows he knows what the
people want he knows
all right all right so
e4 e5 oh we got the kings gambit
i was just a reading about it's the the
the championship of gambits i would
never take it
but if you do want to take it beware
i would never play e5 in the first place
either but
that's because i'm not very good at
chess okay but but that's
that's none in the same
i mean white could just take this pawn
but he's letting letting them have it
letting them keep it all right now he's
got it
and now he's now he won another pawn
big check but but it's this is not a
scary check because
white can just play d4 here and
obviously he's going
to
i would have maybe in this position
maybe attack the b
pawn i always like to make threats and
plus
and plus it keeps that pawn in a pin so
this is looking
awfully awfully well for um
for enterprise
and and usually chess.com
ratings don't matter but this this guy's
better than 1478
so it's going to be a tough one tough
one for him let's go to uh
the hero of round one nick rigon's game
oh and he's battling old loser who we
saw
saw last round oh loser of course
is playing for express scripts
so what is going on how did this one
start well oh he's got another uh
nick is playing with the uh black pieces
so he plays his good old uh
center counter game attacks the queen
oh castle queen side very dangerous when
i've got the
this queen right over here so maybe i
want to play bishop to b4 here probably
or just go straight for the uh
forward big check
uh-oh knight attacks the queen and the a
pawn i'm betty's going to go back to a5
or okay c5 is just as well
attacks the bishop
bishop takes so now the queen has to
take
or else you know bye bye night and now
he's going to get a big discovery here
all right so where do we want to put
this knight to
for rook unfortunately it doesn't have
much of a bite here
there's no real good discovery but
where are we at here
all right so this this is where we left
it all right there is the discovered
attack
he attacks the knight
and so they got the uh
the fork
oh oh and he can't take
the knight he cannot take the knight
because of rook takes check so
unfortunately
old loser dropped a dropped a piece here
but can he get it back
oh good if he got it
back after knight takes f3
if i play rook to h3
where are you going with that knight
well i guess we'll never know i guess
i'll never
ever know look at this
and this knight oh is this is this
knight trapped again
the answer is no well it might have been
well no because if you play rook here
you can go to knight f1
he chooses to go there and now this
knight can just hop to safety
and yeah that's going to be all
she wrote here
check yes i'm still here i'm playing yes
it is
rick takes
oh hey yeah yeah this game is going to
be in the books
so uh nick is probably going to get a
big win for ascension
all right let's check out some other
games here
let's check out uh vindy's game
wow mjc 3801
of
[Music]
bindi vindi is uh just playing uh
another kind of game this this is not
part of the corporate chess league
although it could be but this is not who
he's supposed to play
once again the uh the structure is game
in 10 minutes
automatic rematches so you play one with
the white pieces one with the black
pieces
seven teams competing if you're
interested you have a corporation
and want to know more about it you can
go to st louis chessclub.org
and then you just click on a tab that
says corporate chess league
and then you know you can submit uh
submit an application to join as we said
we'll have another exhibition in
february so if you just want to
try it for one i mean it's all just
about winner take all
fun bragging rights and then we'll get
into the spring league
in march and and we'll have a six-game
season two two in march two in april
two in may and nick did win the uh
the big game
oh we got we got moneyballing
with enterprise this is one of those
extra games so it doesn't count toward
your
your maybe 20 point match total but
every point counts i mean
look how close those scores our
enterprise needs to get the 20 points
by beating umb and then they need some
of these uh
they need to uh to defeat
wwt on these extra boards or else it's
going to be real close
and enterprise the extra players from
enterprise are all playing
uh the wwt team
so this is going to come down to the
wire and this game could
could be the difference so let's check
out moneyballin here
moneyball and playing for our enterprise
how's he playing for wwt
hausey is their board too as you see
he's got a
very respectable chess.com rating of
1743
and he just played f6 the money ball in
i guess he really wanted to protect that
night he was like i'm not moving that
night i'm just going to extra protect it
but we'll see all right let's see what
else is going on here
big daddy jazz 64.
i thought he had a really
good position when we left that if
that's the game we were watching
this king's gambit
but well he's got that past pawn
and now he gave him another pass pawn
but he didn't want it he didn't want it
this is i i think i think big daddy jazz
is
it's a it's a tough one this is a tough
one to handicap right here
i don't know i mean they're dead even in
material three each
and then yeah just maybe he's going to
overextend that pawn though and maybe
he'll get this king going
so the only way to save it now is the e2
and then there'll be one away but uh but
it's always nice
when you're when you uh when you're
trying to defend those uh
past pawns is to actually get your rook
on the queening square to defend it
that's where they want to be
if he was over here it might not be as
easy to defend
but now that he's on the queening square
yeah well
well you want to be very careful to play
king
you can play king f2 your your life is
over because
uh knight d3 check is coming in
oh why didn't why why didn't he play
knight d3 here anyway
what's he gonna do if he plays knight to
d3
oh man he might have lucked out
i don't see a defense
attacking the rook on the queen square
wow knight d2 attacks the rook
just oh maybe we're
well rick check's always nice
but uh i would have just taken the pawn
actually
because now we can defend the pawn and
now you can't defend
i guess you got to just swing it over to
here you might as well get something
when you trade these pawns
oh maybe he's got grand plans of
checkmate
and it's this does save the the d-pawn i
mean these guys
um in the corporate test league they
have some resources
you know that that that's very good
because the point is if rook takes yeah
exactly knight comes in and checks
and that and now now he's got another
check here wrote
any check he wants really and i would
just rook back to g4 with check
i would imagine but who knows
this game is uh pretty exciting
umb is uh hanging in there with the with
the defending
champions the reigning champions of the
corporate chess league enterprise
very exciting
oh i was like oh my god did you just
hang your rook but he did hang the pawn
i don't know why he let him have the
pawn
maybe he's got this trick up his sleeve
where he plays rook check and then if
king
takes then he gets the fork
it's an idea but wow
i wouldn't have let him take it
well yeah big daddy jazz 64's gotta
gotta pull something out here and maybe
a win on time as
as yeah it's just 10 minutes no delay no
increment and then
life goes on
big check
but this is going to be a tough one to
win i mean material is even after all
that
all that happened here
but it might be really tough for big
daddy jazz 64 to uh
to protect this pawn
i don't really want to go away from this
one i want to see the the grand
conclusion of this one i mean this
as you see enterprise well they've got
to win
um this match
for sure in order to uh to eclipse
wwt
well obviously if they don't win the
match then
maybe even ascension has a chance to win
but it's probably just going to go to
wwt
or maybe umb even with two players that
would be astounding that would be the
story of the day
if umb somehow wins the whole thing
bringing two players but i don't see
a feasible way of that happening
but stranger things have happened
i guess we'll never know until uh until
the last checkmate is on the board
oh wow oh this is this is when you have
to calculate but he's only got 50
seconds
oh i think
if he if he just takes and trades off
everything
white has to come over and win that h
pawn
and then if you can win the c pawn you
can easily win the a pawn
but then there's white get like the
opposition or something and then it's
just a stalemate
but at least you can't lose but
i love it i mean this is fighting spirit
in the corporate chess league everybody
wants
to win they're not out for draws
or anything like that they just want to
win
we do have a a quick result in the uh
in the express script ascension match
we'll get right back to this
game well maybe well
we do have a result uh
the player from express scripts got on
the board
neil yes
he won his game so okay back to uh
back to the big game will we see a check
nope because that check would have just
lost the
the pawn it looks like but he's only got
21 seconds so he just needs
i mean it's going to be really tough as
we were saying earlier in the broadcast
if you do the pre-move you uh
you lose 0.1 second a 10th of a second
every time
so he's got to get all the pawns off the
board all the rooks
the other rook off the board and so if
white just has
his uh white knight left at the
conclusion of the game
uh chess.com will declare a draw
because white will have insufficient
mating chances
so yeah so so he's got an easy draw here
just rook to g check and then trade
those off and then just go and win the
uh
the a pawn with your king and here he
goes here he goes can he do it in six
seconds
i think he can if i'm him i just play
okay okay he's just gonna take it but
he could have maybe try to trick him
with a6
assuming that he pre-moves king a5 in
that position
and then you can win go and win the
queen
but he didn't want to do it and um
because even if
black would somehow get a queen with
whatever 1.4
seconds you're not going to lose i mean
so so very interesting so we got a half
point
for uh u m b and
and enterprise all right let's check out
uh oh let's check out the conclusion of
the uh
the moneyballing game this this could
this could be a huge game even though
it's only worth
one point overall i mean this could be
the difference between wwt
getting that extra 10 points and
enterprise might need every point they
can get now to uh
to win this thing this is all it's like
a
it's a winner take all exhibition match
but
it sure doesn't seem like an exhibition
match these guys are
are bringing it no friendly draws
everybody wants to win
but let's see it looks like uh
what is going on it looks like uh it
looks like house is gonna
have this one pretty easy he's up a lot
of on time
and uh material so it's probably going
to be a big win
there let's go back to uh
we saw n burdock
playing for um
express scripts against s
gilmore 999 so s gilmore
got the uh the first win for ascension
and uh so all right let's check out uh
another game here
neil with uh
with express scripts he won the first
game against ascension
and let's see what's going on here
anything big
i give a slight edge for white yeah i
don't want to get back real checkmated i
always like if you
if you don't really know what's going on
in uh in a game
it's never bad just to just to make sure
you don't get backward check made
now just because you made an escape
square for your king
otherwise known as luft l-uft
that still doesn't guarantee that you're
not going to get back row checkmated
as uh if you're ever interested in um
my youtube series beginner breakdown
i have a very popular uh
episode called terrible games analyze
it's one of my
my best ones too and uh i show
uh an example of how they do everything
they
can not to get backward checkmated and
of course the game ends and backward
checkmate it's a very
very funny and and
instructional uh video
check it out you can just google my
comer
terrible right man hopefully that's the
first thing that comes up on youtube or
else i'm in a lot of trouble
all right let's go back to uh
the match of the day uh we have
the enterprise umb
and housing did beat uh moneyballin in
that match
and there aren't to uh game two
halsey with uh wwt
moneyballin for enterprise had a very
clutch win
in round two against edward jones
to uh to get them
ultimately to the armageddon match where
john boyer the team captain of
enterprise
was able to checkmate his opponent with
.3 seconds to take home the 2020
title
oh he's got the big check if he wanted
it he didn't want it no
oh he's up by 13 here yeah i guess big
daddy jazz was like i'm not messing
around
with the king's gambit and everything
and he can't risk that draw so look look
at look at this score
he's got him up by two touchdowns
kansas city missouri shout out to the
chiefs they've got a
big matchup against the buffalo bills in
the afc championship game
5 40 us a central time on
cbs this sunday
don't miss it
oh our producer ben simon actually uh
believe it or not it was that about a
decade ago
actually was part of the pro monday
night
football production crew in kansas city
at arrowhead stadium
no that was well i don't want to digress
too much
but um i found out that he was in kansas
city
and i was like oh are you going to the
game and it's like yeah i'm working it
yes
you got to hold the light wow
but nfl money here here we go
but we are very lucky to work for a
non-for-profit organization
the st louis chess club is a 501 c 3
organization
and we are always looking for a donation
every
every dollar helps especially with our
20 000
square foot expansion hopefully to
conclude
spring slash summer 2021
big things to come
i've looked at the the blueprints it's
it's gonna be great
all right but enough about that that's
it's under wraps right now
but all right and and right in the nick
of time
big daddy jazz got one and a half out of
two for uh
for uh enterprise so yeah
plus 24. so
if you're doing the math at home that's
three touchdowns and three two point
conversions for the championship all
right
all right let's see what else we got
going on let's see the big rematch
between moneyballin and
hausey housey is plus
one but just because you got more
material doesn't necessarily mean you're
winning
but it's looking
[Music]
good for him
in this one let's go back to the uh
let's let's see if we can uh see if
nick risco is updating the standings
here
he'll be
this is a live shot of the standings
well i might even have liver shots
look just give me a one second to uh
digress you can
check out the big game here and um i
might have um
advanced standings here
but you never know you never know all
right
yeah my computer is uh acting funny
all right i do not have liver standing
sorry
these are these are the standings after
round one so obviously wwt
got got 26 and a half points
in round one but got an additional 10
points
right off the bat because they have the
buy in round
two so but if they score uh
they they brought six players so 12
games
so quick math if they score six and a
half out of
12 they will get an additional
10 points so that will bring them up to
46 and a half
and then if you can add 46 and a half
plus six and a half i believe it's 53
that will be their ultimate total and
that would be good enough
to win i i would i i would have to think
so so that's why this this game against
uh moneyballing
could be huge for wwt and huge for
enterprise
i if i had i guess let me see if i can
if i can um
if i can see how kamikaze knight
did in his game
and board one for enterprise because
that could that could determine
everything well not everything but
a big portion
all right here we go kamikaze knight is
offline so
his games have concluded
let's see how he did
kamikaze knight 95 and a half
that's a that's an excellent score for
chess.com
and um so kamikaze knight won both his
games
against against the board one of
umb so umb's uh score is
in the books at 23
and a half which is very respectable
considering they had to play the
defending champion and they only brought
two players
so i mean that's about as as good as you
can get and that means
that means enterprise right now
enterprises
current score okay they they started
with the 29 right
they get the 20 for winning the game so
now they're at 49
and then you add three and a half to
that score
you with me ben simon oh no sorry okay
he's not with me okay
everything's fine as long as you guys
are filing home so
the live score for enterprise well it's
not really live
but it's it's at minimum 52 and a half
right now
but like we said i mean every point
could
and then so wwt is the only other team
that can catch them
so this this moneyballing game could be
what it's all about
very exciting stuff let's see if we can
follow are
you know uh our club manager ryan
chester
is also playing as an extra player today
against wwt
that game could determine the win
and he's playing uh
dv dutch he used to play in our
friday action quads uh with uh
some success back in uh
2019 2020 we do host the secret action
quads
limited to eight players every friday
night
from six to eight three rounds game and
ten with a two second increment
and thirty that six thirty six dollars
to the winner of each
quad
all right let's let's let's let's do see
if uh
how how there if uh if ryan chester is
still playing
um
it looks like that game has concluded
we are winding down
the match tonight the exhibition number
one of the corporate chess league 2021
season very exciting stuff we saw a lot
of fighting spirit
and i can tell you already who who won
the uh
who won the brilliancy prize if there is
a brilliancy prize
maybe the brilliancy presence is just an
exhibition maybe it's just
just knowing that you won the brilliancy
prize is the price
i actually got to play a brilliant move
on chess.com uh
a couple months ago i thought it could
never be done but
truth be told it was it's on uh our
twitch
channel if anybody's interested
all right let's see what this uh
see what other games we have going on
another past pawn it's deep in enemy
territory
see if we can have any okay we are
getting
some uh we are getting some
more results in
currently ascension leads express
scripts three to two
enterprise of course won their match
over umb
arco arco
to one over bear
with i guess a game in progress
wwt
obviously obviously has three here here
comes dv dutch's
uh d.v dutch only could score
a draw against club manager ryan chester
way to represent ryan one and a half
out of two he's good he is good
oh this is not good
so right now it is three and a half
three and a half wwt against the extra
players
they have to win the match
oh and now it's four and a half four and
a half
why it could all come down to this
moneyballing game
let's see how bobby one two one
two did for did for wwt he got a half
wow this could all come down to this
right now
this this is the game of the match
so they have three and a half
four and a half five
three three and a half four and a half
one two three
oh so if housie wins
they will so you need six and a half
points
currently currently the
extra players including ryan chester
have
three currently they have six
while wwt has
5 so they would need to
oh so they're going to be out of
luck it looks like they're going to be
stuck at
forty one and a half plus six
forty one and a half plus six
forty seven and a half
that's the maximum they can get
because they already have the 10 for
drawing the match
and then as i said enterprise at least
has
52 and a half so i'm ready to go out on
a limb and say enterprise
they keep on rocking and rolling with a
john boyer time for her and uh
they won the exhibition number one of
the 2021
corporate chestnut club uh corporate
chess league season
good job the enterprise that is
unofficial
but i'm ready to call it
thank you for our new team uh arko
who uh who came up big with uh
with a win
in uh round number two and uh but
you know it's just getting started this
preseason we'll have another pre-season
uh match
coming up in february so
oh and who won that one housey so he got
the
draw they they got the draw
for uh wwt so every point counts they
could have just got
six and a half they would have been
the grand champions with that extra 10
points
but ryan chester for the club came
through for
enterprise in a big-time way scoring one
and a half
out of two against dv dutch
and uh that's that's the way that's the
way the whole thing ends
and we'll be back ben simon will be back
uh shortly with uh with the brilliancy
prize
and the absolute final standings and
we'll see
if if i was correct with uh all this
math
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to
the pandemic and covet 19 we were able
to gather here
in the chess club meet face to face and
have games on a quarterly basis it was a
lot of fun
had a high level of engagement and
people beginning
to be attracted to that edward jones has
been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on
the corporate chess league once a month
here at edward jones we actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page
and be able to see and interact with
each other
in a virtual way and then partnering
with chess.com we're able to provide
the the actual uh tournament and and how
the competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of uh you know
uh rib each other a little bit and and
it is a little friendly banter which we
love
and all during that time the st louis
chess club is hosting
a youtube channel that has commentary
from
guest speakers grand masters
international masters
commentating on how the games are
actually going
that makes for a lot of fun for people
to be able to
see how their friends how their
colleagues are doing
during a game by having a professional
be able to speak about
the position and and have fun that way
too
i think during this time it is hard
to have motivation sometimes we can get
down on things having an
outlet where competition can still be
involved in your life having an outlet
where you can still have
networking with your colleagues has
really been a key part of the success of
the corporate chess league
it has been really fun to be able to not
only get to know the people in my own
firm better and share that that similar
passion
but also get to know people from several
different
firms here in in the st louis area
we've continued to have interest in the
corporate chess league
both here in the st louis area and
beyond
we're looking forward to a great season
in 2021
if you or your company is interested
in being a part of the corporate chess
league you can go to
www.stlouischessclub.org
and get more information we'd love to
have you be a part of the competition
welcome back to the corporate chess
league exhibition number one
of the 2021 season
i was correct with
the winner of the event
is none other than enterprise
the reigning champion of the corporate
chess league they got
57 points they were also aided by
club manager ryan chester so uh
maybe they can give him a treat next
time uh second place
wwt with 42 and a half
points ascension got
41 and we'll go over how ascension got
41 points in just a moment
bear came in fourth with 24 right behind
just with two players umb scored
a very good 23 and a half points
and then rounding out the standings are
arco and express scripts
arco are brand new team in the league
this year and hey
the more teams the better please join us
uh for
our exhibition next uh next time in
february if you want to get a team
team in you can just email uh
development
louis chessclub.org and they'll be happy
to tell you how to uh
how to how to participate and saint is
spelled out
s-a-i-n-t or you can just go to st louis
chessclub.org and then give all the
information on there
all right but here is the brilliancy
prize
nick ragone game of the night round one
game two
he was playing bear and he knew the game
situation
his bear already had
what what did they have they already had
uh
the six points while uh ascension had
five so so nick knew he had to win to
secure the draw
and we want to take a a real quick look
at the end of this game
uh all right here we go
it's a it's a rook and pawn
ending and
nick is playing with the black pieces
here
and uh captures
and now they double up white doubles up
on the uh
seventh rank big check another big check
and he keeps checking and now he's
trying to
bring his uh a pawn to victory
so right here nick has a draw
but then he's then he realizes hey he's
up 55 and a half points according to the
computer
so he's like no draw
and here we go some more checks
another check some more checks
oh i was recommending f5 in this
position let's see if
the computer likes it nope
nick knows rook takes h2 check is the
best
and yeah on chess.com you can uh go into
your profile and um
and you can analyze your games it's it's
a great
uh great thing to do
to get to get better at just analyzing
your own games with uh
either somebody stronger than yourself
or a super computer
and here he goes a7 and then he keeps
pushing his pawn
and then what a tactic just take the
pawn
rick takes a7 his best and then
that's all she wrote so congratulations
to uh
nick ragon for winning the brilliancy
prize if there is a brilliancy prize but
just knowing that you won
that's all you need to know
congratulations to the grand champion
of tonight of this exhibition enterprise
holdings good night
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club